[Música]
bienvenidos nuevamente a 5 minutos con
israel y hamás llegaron a un acuerdo el
alto el fuego después de 11 días de
escalada bélica la peor desde el año
2014 pero para analizar este tema nos
acompaña aceite chayanne director del
núcleo de estudios de medio oriente de
la universidad austral de argentina
gracias por acompañarnos y estar con
nosotros en france 24 leo la bienvenida
preguntándole que contempla el acuerdo
firmado y si tuvieron en cuenta todas
las realidades por las que atraviesa la
región
bueno qué tal cómo estás buenos días el
acuerdo esencialmente se trata de una
suspensión de las hostilidades entre los
palestinos de hamas y
el ejército israelí no probablemente lo
más destacado que hemos visto de este
acuerdo es el movimiento diplomático que
ha tenido de egipto no y la relevancia
que ha logrado que le han permitido
tomar
en este acuerdo que lo posiciona de una
nueva manera en el escenario de la
región hemos visto hoy ya los palestinos
regresando a sus hogares por lo menos en
la región de cisjordania mucho festejo
también en la franja de gaza
bueno vamos a ver cuánto tiempo dura no
porque en definitiva este acuerdo es
simplemente una tregua no es una
antesala a un acuerdo de paz y la región
vemos siempre está en proceso de
escalamiento y escalamiento es decir
esto es más bien yo diría una pausa no
hasta que tenga lugar
una pausa a lo mejor también un poco
rara porque ya se están registrando
enfrentamientos en el primer día de este
es ese el fuego en explanada de las
mezquitas debido también a que los
musulmanes van a rezar como todos los
viernes que va a pasar realmente está
esta pausa de hostilidades va a ser
duradera
y esperemos que si yo vida en unas
imágenes que vieron ustedes la represión
policial en el méxico de la assa bueno
esperemos que sea un envío de aislado
hasta que digamos las cosas vuelvan a su
carril
yo creo que jamás no tiene incentivos
para seguir bombardeando tampoco los
tiene
el ejército israelí pero no por ahora no
estamos unidos intervino pensemos que
desde el domingo fijamente eeuu está
pidiendo a israel que acepte la tregua o
en bretaña jugar impuso sus propios
términos dijo bueno ya cuando terminemos
la operación vamos a superar la tregua
bueno hacer fue el día creo que ambas
partes se han dado por satisfecha ahora
se ha ido usted está hablaba de egipto
que siempre ha sido una pieza clave para
rebajar la tensión entre israel y el
movimiento islamista de hamás que
controla esta franja de gaza que papel
entonces jugó ahora egipto y qué
relación tiene con hamás
en realidad de egipto se ha mostrado
siempre muy crítico de hamás y en ese
sentido siempre ha rivalizado con otros
actores regionales como por ejemplo
turquía o qatar que se ha demostrado de
una manera más solitarios con este con
este grupo sí y sin embargo a ver qué es
lo importante acá también vemos como
hamás acepta a egipto como un
interlocutor válido y vemos también cómo
de alguna manera a su vez su rol como
decano
de las relaciones con israel en la
región recordemos que el primer acuerdo
de paz que israel firma en el año 78 con
uno de los países árabes
va a ser de egipto a salvo dígito el
famoso acuerdo de cap davis y también
fíjense como como a eeuu le ha permitido
en este acuerdo de negociación posible
sin el auspicio de estados unidos como
eeuu le ha permitido al presidente al
sisi que tome este rol protagónico en
las negociaciones bailén ha recomendado
seguir
seguir este cambio diplomático bueno de
una manera esto lo revaloriza en la
región frente a otros actores que
también tienen aspiraciones de poder
como arabia saudita como turquía
probablemente el discurso tuya fue mucho
más agresivo hacia israel lo que le
impedía alguna manera convertirse en un
mediador legítimo y arabia saudita en
esta cuestión del doble comando entre
digamos la opinión del rey y la opinión
del príncipe de lo que casi no lo hemos
visto en torno a la situación lo que no
impide involucrarse del todo egipto
si son cinco minutos por supuesto nos
quedamos cortos para analizar todo el
complejo escenario de oriente próximo
pero como siempre gracias por estar
nuevamente con nosotros aquí en france
24 estábamos conversando con side saia
directora del núcleo de estudios de
medio oriente de la universidad austral
de argentina hasta aquí llegamos a
nuestro programa cinco minutos pero al
día de hoy continúa con nosotros
[Música]